one of the most painful patterns of
mental life goes by the term ocd
obsessive-compulsive
disorder to the sufferer of ocd there is
something that requires constant
rumination and investigation a poisonous
gas is seeping into the house a sharp
knife may have been left out in the
kitchen and could be seized on by an
intruder there's something inappropriate
they may have looked at online a while
back and the police might be on their
way their skin may be aging prematurely
and they need to look in the mirror
constantly to learn more
there is no use in such cases offering
simple reassurance no matter how often
one shows the sufferer that no gas is
flowing that the knives are locked away
that they haven't done anything bad
online and that they aren't
disintegrating physically it doesn't
work
this is because the true object of
terror lies somewhere else ocd is a
trauma from the past that has been
projected into the future and
metastasized into a paranoia it can
therefore only be solved by persistent
detective work we might through patient
investigation discover that the terror
of gas poisoning had its origins in a
depressed mother who appeared to want to
asphyxiate us in childhood the dread of
a sharp knife might reflect an
unacknowledged fury at a caregiver who
let us down appallingly a fear of arrest
might be connected to a sense of never
being legitimate in one's family of
birth dread of aging might be a
consequence of a parent's rivalrous
jealousy fear has jumped its cause in
random almost poetic ways one has been
left with its shell while its innards
remain protected our minds are likely to
insist that their terror has nothing at
all to do with the past and simply
everything to do with the gas tap or the
dimpled brow we should stay skeptical
before such protests if only because
were we to solve one surface worry
without drilling into its ultimate cause
we'd simply facilitate its movement
elsewhere we need to travel back to the
source of dread and drain it properly
the world will only feel like a safe
place once the unfortunate sufferer
remembers their original injury
localizes it and separates it off from
modern day anxieties as must seem
entirely unbelievable to anyone in the
grip of ocd a day might come when one
has relearned what dreadful event shook
one's foundations and bred ensuing
obsessions and the present can start to
feel as calm and as bearable as it
should always have been
the school of life offers online
psychotherapy to people all around the
world our therapists are highly trained
and accredited and are a vital source of
kindness solace and wisdom for life's
most difficult moments
click the link to find out more